Jim I know you joke about food you've
written about food do you ever think
about the backstory of what a character
you're about to play eats that's a
really interesting question yeah I
suppose I haven't I don't really I mean
I do think II wouldn't we were shooting
Chappaquiddick there was an amount of
there were these scenarios where there's
drinking but I think that's not food but
like there is this approach drinking and
consumption of alcohol that's shifted so
much with every decade at least in my
lifetime so you know this was kind of my
dad's era where people would drink just
you know enormous amounts and they would
day drink and they would drink at night
and yeah it was pretty amazing did you
ever consider what your character might
might eat I know that drinking was a lot
of what was going on especially on those
few days that the show takes place I
think I I would what they would eat yeah
I don't know that's interesting but I
think it's more of the priority of
eating whereas I think for me what I
would eat and the type of food I would
eat is probably more important than what
you know what it was back then it's like
you look back at like barb what we're
having at barbecues as a kids versus
what we're having a barbecue is now it's
it's kind of gotten fancier fondues and
yeah yeah why do you think comedians
make such great actors well I mean
that's very flattering I would say that
comedians you it's really necessary to
know yourself that that's part of the
journey is and that's part of the
conversation you have with the audience
and how they respond to things
particularly autobiographical things
you become very aware of who you are and
how you come across but I don't know I
think of acting and stand-up is very
different disciplines but I also I love
acting because it's in some ways it's
the opposite of stand-up whereas
stand-up I'm writer director producer
and every beatin moment of the show is
controlled and influenced by me I love
the opportunity to be this spoken this
larger just even a moment in a scene
serving a narrative of stories is really
exciting and also it's fun to to kind of
hide in a different character and have a
different a different point of view I
mean I think in my stand-up I kind of
engaged different points of views but in
acting it's really fun to kind of climb
behind a different point of view and see
how they would adjust of course it's
still you but you know like playing Paul
Markham you know he's a lawyer so that's
I think that that influenced how he
viewed everything it was also someone
who really liked Ted so I think those
elements really had an influence whereas
in stand-up there's a greater likelihood
of taking the irreverent point of view
have we learned anything from
Chappaquiddick all these years later or
it's just a moment in time no one really
knows what happened there's there's so
much information out there and some of
the you know some of it the information
is I don't know how how definite is but
I think it's how our viewpoint on
Chappaquiddick is shifting just
particularly in this day and age we live
in so I mean look our viewpoint on
driving has shifted dramatically in our
lifetime I remember being a kid and
hearing about drunk driving like try not
to do it and now no one would do it and
so obviously this tragedy you know no
one should ever do this but it was you
know like the alcohol or the you know
philandering part our judgments on that
have changed dramatically excellent
thank you appreciate it